Continuing in
Kitab al-Tahara min al-Wajiz,
the chapters
regarding wudu, the sub chapter
regarding the instances in which it is
preferable for a person to make will do.
[Silence]
The eighth
instance in which it is preferred for a
person to make will do
is after vomiting.
Whether a person makes himself vomit or
a person is overcome
by the urge to vomit,
then a person is to make will do
and this is something which is
preferred. It is not obligatory. It is
preferred and we'll discuss why that is
in a moment.
[Silence]
So, this narration is in Jami
at-Tirmidhi. It's in Sunan Abi Dawud
that
Thawban
he had narrated
and Abu ad-Darda had heard that Thawban
Thawban is one of the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam's servants.
He's one of the servants that he had. He
had a number of servants though Ben is
one of them and
[Arabic recitation]
they both narrate that the prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam
vomited, he threw up
and
he broke his fast and made wudu.
alayhi salatu wasallam
And we know from the narrations
that
man
istaqa
fal yaqdi sawmahu
[Arabic recitation]
al qay'u
fa fal yutimma sawmahu
In Jami at-Tirmidhi, the prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam tells us
that
whoever is overcome by the urge to vomit
and does so
then their fast is correct. They don't
have to make it up. However, if a person
is to induce
himself to vomit, then he is to make up
his fast. We took this
months ago in the book of fasting of
this same book
during Ramadan.
And so
[Arabic recitation]
sallallahu alayhi wasallam
he
threw up. We don't know why.
Usually it's because somebody eats
something that's unfavorable
or something that went sour, something
of the sort.
And
inducing oneself to vomit is one of the
prophetic
prophetic ways
of
remedy, remedying a sick stomach the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
had
instructed this
and so
with respect to fasting and with respect
to will do they are two different
rulings
with respect to fasting
as we heard if a person
makes himself vomit
then his fast is
his fast is over
and he is to make the day up if it's an
obligatory day of fast
however if he were to vomit
then
you know unintentionally
then his fast is still correct in this
narration we have that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam vomited
and broke his fast and made will do
so it's unclear from this narration
which of the two occurred with him
however it's largely inconsequential
because
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
could have felt unwell unwell enough to
break his fast for the day
alaihis salatu wasallam
but the point here that's taken from the
narration is that he made will do now
this act of making will do
he didn't say make will do if you vomit
there's no narration that we only
have this narration
and we have another narration and a
sunan on the authority of Ali ibn abi
talib radiyallahu anhu
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam vomited and then made will do
and it could be the same same incident
and so him merely doing it and not
commanding it,
this doesn't articulate obligation.
This articulates
that at best, it is preferred.
That is to say,
that is it possible that he broke his
wudu with something other than the
vomiting and him making wudu after
vomiting was incidental? Is that
possible?
It's possible.
There's no way to be certain of that.
As the scholars and the fuqaha have
mentioned
in their discussions regarding this
topic.
And so,
based on these points and others,
if a person is to throw up,
it is preferred
at best that he make wudu.
However, wudu
is not broken by the mere
act of vomiting
or
by
what is
less than that, which is called
al-qalas. Well, qalas is bile,
right, that comes up
from heartburn or something like
that. It comes up into the mouth. This
is called al-qalas.
I then
al- taqayyu, which is full full-on
vomiting. And
some of the madhahib,
it is
considered
obligatory that a person make wudu after
vomiting, that this is considered to be
a an invalidator of wudu, that it will
break a person's wudu. However, these
are the only evidences for that,
along with saying, you know, it's
something that went into the stomach and
then and back out. But, we've largely
seen the pattern of what breaks the
wudu. And the pattern and the essence of
what breaks a person's wudu is
what comes out of the private parts.
This is what breaks a person's wudu. As
we took before the statement of Ibn
[Arabic recitation]
He says that wudu
is from that which comes out of the body
or
and not what goes into the body. We
discussed this before. And so, the point
here is that it remains a sunnah that if
a person
were to
vomit,
that this person is encouraged to make
wudu.
Obligated? No. Encouraged? Yes.
and
you will hear me now rush down there
your team now talk one hour in the world
you that
will go to a lie will will allow Adam
will sell a lot of selling a lot of
[Arabic recitation]